depuis le début de la pandémie 63 % des
québécois ont passé plus de temps devant
les écrans révèle une nouvelle étude
motivé marche quasiment tout est j'en
écoute beaucoup plus la scission avec la
polémique je me suis plus orienté côté
streaming ce que je puisse porter à
l'écouté d'une mission sur netflix s'est
inscrit à des nouvelles plateformes les
dîners plus et tout ça dans cette
enquête baptisée nette tendance 2020 est
réalisé en partenariat avec l'université
laval
on apprend aussi qu à cause de la
pandémie 2020 aura été une année qui a
tout changé pour les géants de la
télévision en continu comme netflix
disney + club illico et tou.tv
c'est un saut presque un coin antique
c'est une grosse transformation
numérique quand les québécois en
véhicule près de 70 % des québécois ont
au moins un abonnement une augmentation
de 30% depuis 2016
du côté de la télévision traditionnelle
72 % des québécois demeure abonnés une
baisse de 12% depuis 2017
moi je vois ça comme une année charnière
dans l'évolution à delà du
divertissement télé des québécois parce
qu'ils sont encore plus branché à la
maison ils ont même augmenté alors leur
vitesse de téléchargement
le géant disney a annoncé récemment
avoir 87 millions d'abonnements pour son
service des plus lancé il ya près d'un
an
les studios warner ont décidé eux de
lancer la cuvée 2021 de leur film donc
d'une et la matrix 4 sur leurs
plateformes et du bio max et ce en même
temps que dans les salles de cinéma
comme vélo si la tendance se poursuit la
façon d'accéder à la télévision
traditionnelle ou aux productions qui
sont à faire par les diffuseurs
traditionnels mais va changer ça va être
beaucoup plus niché à la carte
dans cette bataille de titans du contenu
numérique au québec
netflix arrive premier suivi par amazon
prime vidéo club illico des plus graves
et ici tout point de vue extra on a vu
où sept points td oui une augmentation
du nombre d'abonnés mais aussi une très
grosse augmentation du temps passé de
l'ecoute c'est à dire que les gens quand
je le disais ont du temps et on a vu
qu'il y avait un appétit pour tous les
styles de contenu ce halo
si l'année 2020 a été faste pour les
plateformes de diffusion en continu
est-ce que 2021 le sera tout autant je
pense quand même que même si certaines
personnes vont se désabonner le pommier
fed vers l'avenir les gens ont adopté
cette façon d'écouter l'heure je crois
que ça va rester
la télévision est en transformation et
pendant l'année 2021 nous assisterons
sans aucun doute à une guerre des
contenus ici louis fait déprimer
radio-canada m'ont rien